the movie opens up in a small town where
a man named Dell breaks into a house he
removes all the batteries from the
electronic devices and keeps them with
him then in a shocking twist he cleans
up the entire house as if it were his
own before leaving he also steals a
picture that belongs to the owners once
outside Dell marks the street in front
of the house with spray paint at this
time we can see several other houses on
the street with similar signs revealing
that Dell has already broken into them
Dell believes that he is the last person
alive on Earth an unknown cause is
apparently wiped out the entire
population leaving our protagonist alone
and sad to cope with his Solitude he has
settled into a very unusual routine thou
lives in the library where he used to
work and takes great care of the books
making sure that they are well organized
and protected to sustain himself he
gathers food from supermarkets he has
also taken up fishing as a hobby since
there are still plenty of fish in the
lakes and most importantly he visits
random houses every day cleans them up
collects any photos and useful items
like batteries and gasoline for his
truck and brings all the books back to
the library he also makes sure to mark
all the houses he has already visited
one day during his daily routine Dell
breaks into a house and discovers two
dead bodies without any hesitation he
wraps them up tightly with a bed sheet
after this he loads the corpses into his
truck he then drives to a field drags
the bodies to an empty grave and buries
them in the ground at night as Della's
sleeping in his room he is startled
awake by a loud explosion quickly
springing into action he peeks through
the window and sees fireworks in the
distance this indicates that someone
else is also present in the town however
since it is already dark Dallas too
scared to confront whatever lies there
he simply goes back to sleep hoping it
is nothing dangerous that could have
been Shakira out there and delve would
never know the following morning as Dell
is Scavenging for supplies he again
hears something unusual this time it is
a car alarm which has gone off Bell
locates the car and notices that it is
crashed into a wall when he slowly
approaches it he is shocked to discover
a girl lying unconscious in the driver's
seat Shakira there is also a gun in the
back seat in the next scene the young
woman Grace wakes up and finds herself
in the bedroom with a bandage on her
head she feels nauseous and attempts to
open the door only to discover it's
locked when she starts yelling for help
dull arrives at the door without opening
it he inquires if anyone else was with
her and why she was carrying a gun in
response Grace explains that she hasn't
seen anyone else and that she found the
gun on the road she was only keeping it
for safety but despite the explanation
Dell is skeptical ever so he decides to
send her away once outside Grace wonders
why she can't smell the decomposing
corpses and Dell informs her that he has
already buried them he then hands her
the car keys and asks her to leave but
Grace wants to stay with him she is
scared that she might die of hunger or
disease however Del coldly ignores her
police and walks away later Grace can be
seen following Del quietly around the
city wherever he goes she even observes
him while he is fishing eventually she
follows him back to the library and
offers to help him clear the dead bodies
in town this finally changes Dell's mind
and he shares his food with her when she
asks him about the sudden disappearance
of people he refuses to engage in casual
conversation or discuss theories about
the cause of the Apocalypse however the
persistent girl keeps on talking she
asks Dell if he has ever felt lonely to
which he replies that it does not matter
to him because he has always been lonely
since his birth hearing his cold
responses Grace realizes that he isn't
interested in companionship and decides
to leave but as she reaches the car Dal
has a sudden change of heart he quickly
approaches earned asks if she wants to
stay with him excited Grace immediately
accepts and rushes inside the Library
this may Mark the first time a librarian
has ever gotten laid the next day she
settles into the same room where Dell
brought her after her accident during
the day while driving around Dell
notices Grace heading towards a locality
which he hasn't cleared yet worried he
approaches her and emphasizes the
importance of following his specific
cleaning methods he then starts teaching
her all the steps right from searching
for the batteries to collecting all the
books later on they visit a house and
load some corpses in their truck when
it's time to bury them Grace suddenly
asks if they're going to pray because it
is a very sensitive procedure Dell
mentions that he has never done so but
when the persistent girl insists he
closes his eyes for 10 seconds and
chance a few words one day as Grace is
walking through the streets she hears a
dog barking from a nearby house being an
animal lover she quickly enters the
house retrieves the small dog and brings
it back to the library Dell is taken
aback to see the puppy but he allows her
to keep it anyway later when Grace asks
for help in naming the dog Dell refuses
so she simply names it dog the next
morning Grace briefly looks at a scar on
her neck indicating that she has had a
troubled past she hides it completely
with her hair and then heads to the
library there as Dell is rearranging
some books he notices the dog chewing on
a magazine enraged he tries to pick it
up but ends up getting bitten on the
hand the following day grace wakes up
and finds that the dog is missing she
frantically informs Dell about it and
the latter admits that he had to let the
dog out to urinate shortly after as the
two are searching the locality it
suddenly Dawns on Grace the Dell has
killed the dog for biting him the other
day also maybe because their names were
too similar when they returned to the
library Grace drinks a lot of wine to
drown her Soros she then enters Dell's
room and places his collection of photos
on the table in an intoxicated State she
points out that Dell doesn't know any of
the people in the pictures and that he
treats them as mere objects after this
she reveals that she was with a boy when
the apocalypse took place he cared for
her and always kept her happy unlike
Dell who was always alone in a fit of
rage Grace then grabs the photos and
throws them at him before storming out
of the room the next day Dal realizes
his mistake and invites Grace to a
greenhouse he explains to her that there
are still many houses that need to be
cleared and asks for her help but also
assures her that she's not obligated to
assist surprisingly Grace forgives him
and agrees to help him later as they are
cleaning up a house they find a pair of
walkie-talkies and start using them this
helps them Bridge the communication gap
between them and by the end of the week
the duo manages to clean up all the
houses in the neighborhood in the next
scene Grace embarks on a journey on her
bike and discovers an unmarked house
using the walkie-talkie she contacts
Dell and summons him to the place but
surprisingly as soon as he arrives there
he gets emotional it turns out it is
Dell's own house and he has never
visited the place after the apocalypse
happened the corpses of his family
members still lay in their rooms but
Dallas too scared to confront them
hearing this story Grace offers to help
him out Dell also gathers some courage
and together the two Wipe Out the whole
place in no time and head home afterward
during a car ride Grace attempts to
share information about her Origins with
Dell the latter also becomes curious and
stops the car however instead of
speaking she suddenly kisses him the
next day Dell wakes up to the sound of
someone laughing in the dining room
worried he grabs a gun and slowly heads
downstairs only to discover a man and a
woman with Grace Dell is shocked to see
other people as he was under the
impression that they were the only ones
alive on the planet the man introduces
himself as Patrick and claims that Grace
is his daughter he questions why Grace
never told Dell about them and urges her
to reveal the truth after some
hesitation Grace admits that Patrick and
violet are not her real parents but her
foster ones this leaves Dell completely
baffled and he has nowhere words to say
when the situation becomes awkward
Violet breaks the Silence by asking
Grace to pack her things she insists
that they will be returning home to
California later as Patrick is talking
about his golf France he realizes the
Dell is unaware of other survivors he
then scolds Grace for an uninforming
dull about the thousands of survivors
and reveals that they have placed signs
on highways across the country to guide
people to their Community enraged that
so much had been kept from him Dell
walks out of the house and prepares to
leave Grace follows him and confesses
that Patrick and violet are not her
actual parents she explains that she was
assigned to be with them when she
arrived in California Dell expresses his
disappointment with grace for lying
about them being the only survivors and
she admits that she was afraid he
wouldn't let her stay if he knew the
truth Grace desperately pleads with thou
to take her with him however when she
tries to prevent him from leaving by
holding onto the steering wheel he
forcefully removes her hand and drives
away later Patrick visits the library
and asks Dell for audiobooks but the
latter ignores him kind of psychopath
wants to listen to a narrator he says
despite this Patrick compliments Dell's
intelligence and suggests that they
could use someone like him in California
he explains that their commune has
doctors who discovered ways to unlock
the potential of the human brain however
doll remains uninterested and dismissive
when he doesn't reply to anything
Patrick writes his address in a book and
leaves it with Dell and Casey changes
his mind after a while Grace tearfully
watches Dell as they drive away from the
library on their journey to California
for the next few days Dell remains
focused on his work and tries to avoid
any sort of distraction but then he
begins missing Grace and ultimately
becomes depressed he sometimes turns on
the walkie-talkie hoping to hear her
lovely voice one day Dell looks through
his photo collection and reminisces
about the people in the pictures
overwhelmed by loneliness he decides to
visit Grace and searches for the book
with Patrick's address after finding it
he's sets off for California in his
truck during his journey Dell encounters
a blocked Bridge with cars and deceased
people however he does not stop and
change his cars to continue the journey
eventually after changing a couple of
cars and nearly finishing his supplies
he arrives at his destination Dell
notices the family from the glass door
but he waits for the parents to fall
asleep at night once the lights in the
living room are off he enters the house
with a gun in hand he goes straight to
Grace's room hoping to surprise her but
sees something shocking instead Grace is
in a deep sleep connected to an ECG
monitor she has also been injected with
stitches on her neck worried Dell
quickly wakes her up removes the wires
and apologizes for letting Patrick take
her as they try to leave Patrick walks
into the room and orders Grace to go
back to bed he then reveals to doll that
he is doing all this to eliminate
negative emotions like anger sadness and
guilt this will effectively Wipe Out the
entire history before the apocalypse
occurred as Patrick continues explaining
his ideology Grace unexpectedly snatches
Dell's gun and shoots him this kills
poor Patrick on the spot shortly after
Violet arrives at the scene with a calm
demeanor she appears to be totally
unaffected by the death of her husband
this reveals that her emotions have
already been compromised the next
morning Grace carries her goldfish out
of the house and gets into a car with
Dell as they drive away he observes the
town's cheerful residence busy with
their activities the movie ends as Dell
plays loud rock music and gently Smiles
at Grace subscribe for more videos like
this turn on notifications and leave a
like to help the channel out thank you
for watching